a train crash in Pakistan has killed at
least 35 people and injured dozens of
others the Train derailed between
Karachi and Rawalpindi in the Northeast
the government says the crash
investigation will focus on mechanical
failure or possible sabotage let's bring
in our correspondent Zane bus driver
he's joining us live on the site of the
crash in nawab Shah so what's happening
there now Zane
well as we're here in the Sin Province
the town of sarhari where there is a
train station is just a few kilometers
in this direction the train was headed
towards nawab shine Beyond and with the
local police officials are telling us is
that the train began to experience
problems just near the town of Sahari
the wheels of the cars began to lock up
it started to skip and just here is
where things began to get really bad the
trains started to jump off the tracks a
bit and you can see the point of impact
a train car hit this bridge and that's
where the derailment became very very
serious now Witnesses tell us that it is
this train car from which they pulled
the largest number of the Dead they say
only two or three people survived in
this train car there's another train car
we saw that looked bent in half you know
large pieces of metal just completely
bent in half so what we're seeing here
is this trained car people have been uh
it has been moved the dead were removed
from this and the survivors were taken
to the town of navabsha just off uh just
above this uh wreckage you can see where
repair work has already begun on
repairing these vital rail links these
are Travel and Transport links they they
move goods and people and there are
trains waiting on the tracks for areas
to be built a few feet at a time for the
trains to continue traveling there are
no alternatives to these rail links but
these are very old British era rail
links the trains in any other country
may be used as Museum pieces but in
Pakistan they are repaired they are
refurbished and they continue to be used
as an important part of the rail
transport system that people say does
need to be modernized and if if the
train system here is not modernized soon
it it's not a matter of if an accident a
tragedy like this will happen again it's
it's a question of when all right Sam
thank you very much for that that is
Zane Bas Ravi live in sadhari thank you